et je trouve que c'est dégueulasse
qu'une émission telle que la leur puisse
écraser des jeunes artistes qui croient
en eux alors il y a ceux qui ont plus ou
moins de talents mais il faut qu'on
arrête c'était les de merde
on les a fait découvrir en France il y a
cette image de Cindy Sanders la nouvelle
star on s'arrête là et vous dites tout
est manipulé dans les maisons bien sûr
ça veut dire quoi tout est manipulé de A
à Z puisque je j'arrive au casting on me
fait doubler une file d'attente de 8h
parce que j'ai le physique qu'ils ont
envie ils ont des critères ensuite on me
ramène on me dit voilà non non il faut
pas chanter ça et ça il faut faire un
medley il faut en faire des caisses il
faut faire beaucoup de mouvements ce que
je fais et en fin de compte on me dit de
on fait venir des caméras là le
lendemain chez moi en organisent un
concert qui n'a pas lieu du tout
on ne fait croire que je suis vraiment
la gagnante de de cette émission
jusqu'au bout et encore avant de rentrer
en plateau me dit Cindy on sait ce que
la production cherche faisant des
caisses c'est toi la Nouvelle Star cette
année